it's an overcast morning on the Moroccan
coast near Agadir but the muscle harvest
has to go on these women collect some 50
kilos of the shellfish per day it's
their main source of income the women
who come from a village called - IRRI
have increased their wages by joining
together to form a co-op they've also
set up a small factory where the mussels
can be cleaned dried and packed that's a
huge improvement over the way they used
to work thanks to modern technology we
now cook with gas and we've got these
large parts in the old days we used to
steam the mussels in tin cans for
instance paint cans on an open fire for
fuel we used old clothing plastic and
shoes junk basically and we used to
drive the mussels on the ground where
birds and cats came and ate them up the
women used to sell their muscles on
roadsides for the equivalent of one and
a half euros per 500 grams better
processing methods mean they now earn
about three times what they used to
Martin Tampa and Fareed we'd air from
the German Agency for International
Cooperation the GI z helped the women
get started the project is also aimed at
helping Moroccans adapt to the
challenges of climate change the BRIC
anta admits very much the traditional
way of coping with climate deviation is
no longer practicable here so we need to
find new forms of cooperative living off
the land and earning an income in common
sorrowful
to find out what that means for
residents of Morocco's villages and
cities we traveled to the center of the
country the two GIS egg workers are on
their way to visit other innovative
projects suddenly a herd of camels
appears on the road these animals used
to be fairly scarce in these parts
but as we learn from talking to the
mayor of the town of 8 Baja nomadic
camel herders are becoming a problem and
at the root of that problem is climate
change
nobody specie the never used to travel
this far but because of the lack of
water in neighboring regions the nomads
not bring their herds here that
threatens the local agriculture the
cultivation of Argan trees is immensely
important here and the camel herds are a
threat
camels feeding on Argan trees may look
peaceful and harmless but they're the
source of conflict between nomads and
local residents thus far no one has
found a solution to the problem and an
even bigger challenge for a baja is to
normalize the water supply when there
isn't enough rain the river dries up
completely three years ago there was too
much rain resulting in massive floods
too little too much there's no chance
for lasting stability in this region if
people don't learn to deal with extreme
community leaders sought expert advice
and an idea emerged let's get down our
focus is on letting water seep into the
ground in mountainous regions so that it
gets added to the groundwater we want to
divert water away from the river beds so
as to limit flood damage to buildings
settlements and agricultural areas seed
lumen untanned in lancet roughly
inflation suffering
Moroccans are going to have to learn to
think differently if they're to
successfully deal with climate change
one obvious way forward is to exploit
the potential of solar energy in North
Africa the town of wowza that will be
home to the world's largest solar energy
facility it's being partially funded by
Germany in future this is where energy
will be produced and fed into the
national power grid the facility is
scheduled for completion in 2015 and
should be a vital resource in a country
largely without oil and gas reserves
this is a leading project in the world
in addressing the the environmental
problems related to using fossil fuels
but also it's a project that is going to
give Morocco some independency on the
energetic side so it is very well thin
and very well considered by the whole
Moroccan population the words of that
project is a massive undertaking but
smaller ideas also make a difference we
dare and tamper travel on to the village
of tomato fella we're a cooperative is
trying to improve agricultural harvests
the project functions without a lot of
money so it could serve as a model for
other projects and cooperatives
Miriam and Rukia a kadal are part of the
initiative which aims at strengthening
sustainable farming in the region a drip
irrigation system of watering crops has
been introduced to deal with chronic
water shortages local women have been
taught how to avoid monocultures and use
compost heaps in addition to the new
watering techniques there are a lot of
advantages to using drip irrigation
normal methods are difficult because it
hardly rains here drip irrigation allows
us to collect water and use it on our
fields there are a lot of economic and
other advantages all of which means
these women have a good chance of living
from agriculture in future despite
climate change